hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a South Korean show called
melting Me Slowly spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
[Music]
in a secret lab a bunch of alive people
are frozen by a doctor the plan is to
keep them in this state for a week and
calculate if they age unfortunately
during the procedure the device
malfunctions and the people are left to
freeze for an indefinite time 20 years
later two of them finally regain
Consciousness but they are unaware that
the outside world has changed completely
following this we are taken to the year
1999 and introduced to the protagonist
go Miran a beautiful and Lively young
girl she is trying to find a decent job
to support her family which consists of
her parents and her differently abled
younger brother Nam Tay one morning
Miran gets a phone call informing her
that she has been rejected from the job
interview she recently attended sad she
sits to have breakfast with her family
when suddenly the phone rings again
Miran gets a surprise invitation to
attend a variety experiment show which
is being directed by a handsome rich man
modang Chan ma dong wishes he was
handsome in the following scene despite
her unwillingness May Iran visits the
show and participates in some dangerous
experiments just so that she can get
enough money for her family she is made
to fly in the air pull a truck and risk
her life in other experiments as
expected dong Chan is impressed by her
boldness so he Praises her performance
later he wins the most popular TV show
award for his variety experiment and
while receiving it he introduces his
girlfriend Hai young to everyone she is
a news reporter and it seems like she
and Dong Chan have been together for a
long time after the massive success
dongchan now plans to take his variety
show to another level he wants to
conduct a freezing cryonics experiment
in which a living human is frozen and
put in cryo sleep for 24 hours however
the only catch is that he wants to
extend the time limit and store the
human body for a long time dongchan
believes that if they succeed they can
cure different diseases in the future he
also wishes to broadcast the whole
experiment and is looking for a female
participant following this dongchan
sends his assistant hyung hee to meet
Moran and persuade her to participate in
the experiment alongside him he also
talks to his girlfriend and asks her
permission to let him participate though
she refuses at first dongchan does not
stop pleading with her until she finally
agrees next young he meets Moran at a
restaurant and tells her about the whole
experiment he even promises her a lot of
cash but Moran walks away from there
saying the experiment is very dangerous
afterward Moran goes to a fortune teller
and asks to reveal her future the latter
says that she will meet her boyfriend
after 20 years and the climate around
her will be very cold sounds like it's
time to hibernate on the other hand
dongchen can be seen trying to persuade
his boss to let him do the experiment
and broadcast it to their Channel at
first his boss hung Suk refuses his
proposal but later when dongchan tells
him that he can be popular in a short
time because of the show he immediately
agrees later dongchan approaches Miran
and personally requests her to accompany
him in the cryogenic experiment he also
assures her that if she agrees he will
bring the autographs of his brother's
favorite artists and and pay her a huge
amount this finally convinces Miranda
and she agrees to volunteer for the
experiment later at night the two are
inside the freezing capsule and
dongchan's assistant hyung hee is
filming the whole process in the
laboratory we noticed Professor Huang
keeping a close eye on the experiment he
is the one who invented the procedure
but he hasn't revealed how to reverse it
after a while when the procedure is
about to be complete Professor Huang
enters the lab and urges hyung he and
the others to leave the place instead he
calls the student gibiam and asks him to
look after the volunteers while he goes
out to finish some important work as
soon as Huang leaves the laboratory in
his car we see a mysterious man
following him later Wang's car explodes
and flips in the middle of the road in
the next scene the time of the cryogenic
experiment comes to an end but gibiam
has no idea how to stop it panicked he
turns off the power of the whole
laboratory causing the capsules of all
six volunteers including dong Shannon
Miran to disappear the following day the
police force and other Representatives
start searching for the missing people
all over the town seeing this the boss
Hong Suk calls hyunki to his office and
asks him to not tell anyone about the
experiment he also orders that all the
evidence regarding it to be destroyed
immediately later he also meets dong
Chan's girlfriend ha young and tells her
the same thing she tries to revolt but
when hongsuk offers her the position of
the main anchor on the 9 o'clock news
she agrees ha young immediately gets to
work and reports the breaking news where
several people went missing the news
shocks many people across the country
including Nam Tay as he was very close
to his sister he starts remembering all
the Beautiful Moments he spent with
Miran on the other hand after the news
broadcast ends Hae Young sits alone in
the studio and reminisces about her
first meeting with dong Chan she breaks
down in tears and regrets taking up the
offer right then we are shown a secret
room where Professor Huang is sleeping
on a bed and it looks like he is still
alive and someone is looking after him
slowly time passes by and both Miranda
and Dong Chan's family start getting on
with their lives but one day miran's
parents receive a letter from an
anonymous sender saying that their
daughter is safe but they need to keep
it a secret for their safety however
they simply think someone is joking with
them a few months later when their
business fails the family moves out of
the city meanwhile Moran's friends have
graduated and gotten new jobs but they
still miss her the scene then fast
forwards by 20 years to 2019 when Hong
Suk has become the CEO of the media
company and hyung Ki is handling the
variety experiments show namte has also
grown up and dongchan's former assistant
ha young is one of the lead anchors of
the newsline TV channel meanwhile gibiam
who is attending an International
Conference gets a notification on his
iPad about a warning from the laboratory
immediately he turns on the cameras and
notices that Professor Huang has
regained Consciousness and is out of his
bed without wasting any time he leaves
the conference and heads straight to the
laboratory at the moment Huang is trying
his best to alter the experiment that he
started 20 years ago so he opens the
capsules of both Moran and dongchan and
injects them with something as soon as
he does so Huang falls to the ground
while Moran and dongchan regain
Consciousness one by one both of them
head out of the laboratory before gibiam
arrives Miran walks towards her house
whereas dong Chan makes his way towards
the studio where he used to work
unfortunately the latter's body cannot
withstand the high temperatures of the
surroundings so he passes out in the
middle of the road later dongchan is
brought to a hospital and the doctors
are surprised to see him in extremely
normal condition except for the fact
that his body temperature is much lower
than that of a normal human being soon
dongchan wakes up and asks the doctor to
inform hyung HEI about his presence
having no idea about what he is saying
the doctor calls on the number dong
provided him and asks young Ki if he
knows someone by the name of dong Chan
as soon as hyunki hears the name he
becomes shocked and rushes to the other
room away from his Juniors meanwhile
dong scolds him for not recording the
entire experiment and leaving him alone
in the laboratory it turns out that he
has no idea that he has woken up after
20 years somehow dongchan's family also
gets information about him being at the
hospital when they arrive there and see
him alive and well they start fainting
one after another meanwhile hyunki calls
Hong Suk and informs him that dong Chan
is back and that their career is in
danger the Revelation shocks the cunning
CEO so he quickly rushes to his office
without informing anyone on the other
hand Moran reaches her house and finds
it all empty this makes her assume that
her parents have been chased away after
being unable to pay the house rent hence
she goes to the police station and shows
her identity as expected the officers
are shocked to see her young face not
matching the age on her ID card after a
while Miran borrows the telephone and
makes a call to her mother when she does
not pick up she is compelled to leave a
voice message for her mother in the next
scene Moran's mother finally gets the
voice message and rushes to the police
station to get her daughter
unfortunately Miranda's already left and
she is now at her University startled by
the modern gadgets that the students are
using elsewhere hyunki and Hong Suk
arrive at the hospital and as soon as
they see dongchan they start crying it's
been 20 years since we've seen dong
however our protagonist does not
recognize them and starts wondering why
everyone is looking so old he then walks
out of the hospital room and notices a
board revealing that the current year is
2019. similarly Miran also walks around
the university and finds the year to be
2019 we are then shown side by side
scenes of both characters who are left
in utter disbelief after finding out
that they have been asleep for 20 years
next miran's family finally finds her at
the University and they engage in an
emotional reunion Miranda is then taken
to her new lavish family house where her
mother informs her that she founded a
company with the funds Miran gave her
before she was frozen in the experiment
and with their businesses earnings they
are now living a better life Miran has
been away for a long time but it turns
out that her family has prepared a
separate room for her making her
emotional in the next scene dong Chan
also returns home with his family
despite being extremely rich before the
cryogenic experiment the family now
operates a basic restaurant and lives in
a much smaller house than before
dongchan discovers that his younger
brother is now married and has a
daughter not only that he also learns
that his father passed away years ago
making him upset elsewhere Hyun Ki and
Hong Suk are concerned that Don Chan's
return would jeopardize their careers by
revealing information about the
experiment that they have been hiding
from others the following day Don Chan
returns to the laboratory to learn what
actually happened to him and the other
volunteers during the experiment there
he meets gibiam and finds out that at
the very end of the experiment someone
tried to murder Professor Huang 20 years
ago although he survived his team faked
his death to protect him from other
impending risks he regained
Consciousness a few days ago and
resurrected dongchan and Moran from
their sleep but soon after he again
passed out and now he is in intensive
care hearing all of this dongshan
deduces that the perpetrator attack
Professor Huang is connected to his
cryonics experiment following this
dongchan invites ha young to meet him at
a cafe after she arrives he has taken
aback to see her old face and apologizes
for not being able to keep up with his
promise despite this hyung forgives him
and mentions that she is happy to see
him alive later she starts crying and
walks away from there but not before
telling dong Chan that she will call him
later meanwhile gibiam keeps an eye on a
dolphin that was previously part of the
experiment and finds that it is died due
to hypothermia
ah he then speculates that dongchan and
Miran will suffer the same fate if they
continue staying in normal conditions
givion talks to one of his colleagues
and mentions that the only person who
can save them is Professor Huang but
sadly he is still unconscious at the
hospital nonetheless he immediately
caused dong Chan and tells him to
maintain his body temperature not higher
than 33 degrees Celsius next an enraged
Miran arrives at the studio confronts
dong Chan and holds him accountable for
her loss of 20 years she is very upset
to have lost such a huge chunk of her
life sleeping in a capsule so to
compensate for this she demands that the
program director pay her an amount
however dongchan informs her that he too
is a victim of the experiment and is
unable to help her following this Miran
visits her previous University and
declares that she wants to continue her
studies one day her boyfriend from 20
years back beung Sim who is now an
instructor at the same University
notices her Miran however does not
recognize him and walks past him
meanwhile while Tong Chan comes to the
studio and informs Hong Suk that he
wants to resume his career as a program
director as expected the cunning CEO
stops him right away and tries to divert
the topic because he is afraid that
dongchan might expose their secret
nonetheless Hong Suk appoints him as a
junior level director and allows him to
join the studio as soon as he gets
appointed dong Chan scolds young Ki for
his lack of control over the employees
later he is approached by ha young who
tells him that she is free during the
weekend and wants to meet him dong Chan
who couldn't even fap for 20 years
immediately accepts The Proposal later
at night Miran returns home and opens
her brother's laptop to check her emails
to her surprise she finds emails from
her best friends from 20 years ago it
turns out that her mother lied to them
saying that Moran moved to the U.S to
continue her studies the next day Moran
sits to have dinner with her family and
her parents suggest she not work hard to
find a job they assure her that the
family's Financial condition is not like
before and that they can afford
everything now later Miranda tends her
class at the University and
coincidentally the subject teacher is
none other than Beyond Sim she does not
recognize him but as soon as being Sim
notices her in his class he gets nervous
and starts shivering meanwhile dongchan
joins the variety experiments group in
the media company but he gets
ill-treated by an employee named Park on
his first day park makes fun of his
appearance and tells him that he is too
good to learn directing and work for the
program right then hyunki arrives there
and notices the two arguing he
immediately pulls Park away scolds him
and then apologizes to dong Chan for his
subordinate's behavior despite this
dongchan scolds young Ki and belittles
him for not being able to teach some
manners to his Juniors some time later
the whole team sits for a meeting to
discuss ideas for their upcoming show
when it's dong Chan's turn he presents
some of his ideas but they are all
primitive and uninteresting as a result
he doesn't get any response from the
others later Yankee receives a call from
Miran asking him to meet her and take
care of her memorandum hearing this
hyunki immediately heads to Hong suk's
office and reminds him of the on the
other hand Professor Huang regains
Consciousness yet again but sadly he has
lost his memory gibiam tries his best to
help him back to normalcy when none of
his methods work he takes the professor
to the laboratory and makes him look at
the freezing capsules he designed
earlier however the Old Man simply keeps
staring at the capsules the following
day Miran visits the studio and meets
with dong Chen hyung hee and Hong Suk
wasting no time she blames them for
wasting 20 years of her Youth and asks
for compensation according to the rate
she was paid for 24 hours of the
experiment hyung hee and Hong Suk
calculate the amount and figure it out
that it is over 35 billion yen so the
cunning CEO quickly refuses the
compensation saying that Miran is still
young and alive in the next scene
miran's best friends are surprised to
get a reply email from her and
immediately contact her soon they meet
at a restaurant and are shocked to see
Miran young and beautiful like in her
youth they touch her skin and ask her
about its secret as Miranda is forbidden
to disclose the experiment she tells her
friends that she used some good cosmetic
products in the US on the other hand
dongchan goes on a date with ha young
and compliments that she looks beautiful
even after 20 years while they are
conversing he opens his mobile phone and
reads a recent article on himself
questioning his disappearance and the
possibility of him being engaged in a
cryonics experiment miran's friends also
see the news and suspect that she is
hiding something from them elsewhere
dongchan's mother gets enraged at the
news and prepares to head to the
broadcasting company's office to scold
the director however as she is about to
leave her granddaughter stops her saying
that her uncle becoming famous can be a
good thing for their family business
afterward dog Chan visits the laboratory
and meets gibeon during their meeting
the latter shows him the cryonic
capsules which still have some
volunteers captured inside gibiam also
reveals that after the experiment his
normal body temperature is 31 degrees
Celsius and the critical temperature is
33 degrees Celsius later dongchan meets
a detective who investigated Professor
huang's murder attempt and gets
information about the prime suspect in
the case while explaining about his
condition to the detective dong Chen
learns that the general public have no
idea about the experiment they conducted
20 years ago the scene then shifts to
Lee seuck do the CEO of a powerful
company named The Unsung group he orders
his subordinate to do a background check
on dong Chan and also investigate
Professor Huang if the latter is alive
he has to be killed immediately
surprisingly Lee looks exactly like a
man who is still trapped in one of the
cryonics experiment capsules in the
final scene Don Chan returns to the
office and confronts young Ki for not
trying to search for him and informing
the authorities after he disappeared in
response hyung he tries to defend
himself by stating that he was
influenced by Hong Suk and that his
hands were tied right then Moran also
arrives there looking for dong Chan and
requests him to find a job for her at
the same broadcasting station the
episode ends as ha young looks at the
two with regret in her eyes he has
started to realize that he made a big
mistake by not informing the authorities
earlier to see what happens next watch
the second part in series recapped